imagine this one day you're walking home
through the forest when suddenly a pale
stranger appears this stranger appears
tall and thin and while he may appear
friendly at first his motives are
malevolent this stranger is called a
tick belong a ghostly creature from
Filipino folklore and usually appears in
one of three forms an old man a monkey
or a half human half horse hybrid The
Tick belong is known for its cruelty and
penchant for chaos it intends to bring
ill fate upon his victims should you
encounter The Tick belong beware for it
may try to pull you off your path and
leave you abandoned and lost the tick
belong is also said to bring sickness
upon its victims or Worse death so if
you do encounter the tip long in the
forest one day don't engage and don't
get pulled off the path otherwise you
might never get out of the forest again